sie werden sich auch schon ihren teil
gedacht haben wo sie mich gesehen haben
rocker böse kommt irgendwas
dementsprechend wolle man das mal ein
bisschen aufarbeiten ich könnte dir werd
ich auch kurz machen und sagen
ersetzen sie einfach film mit musik oder
mit rockmusik von vorhin und wir sind
durch also da sind wir auch sehr
ähnlichen ebenen
da ich aber dann doch soziologe bin
schauen wir uns das thema natürlich im
diesel aus anderen perspektiven auch
noch an die rockmusik böse
bösartigkeiten inszeniert anhand
verschiedener aspekte die ich auf machen
will und der soziologe bin schaue ich
natürlich in brüssel aus einer anderen
perspektive als der rein ästhetischen
auf das ganze thema
wir fangen erst mal kurz mal die
vorurteile des bösen in der rockmusik
darzustellen ich denke jeder von ihnen
hat auch seine eigenen vorurteile
gegenüber rockmusik auch wenn sie es
vielleicht vor sich selbst leugnen als
objektive wissenschaftler aber man kommt
nicht aus gewisse zuschreibungen zu
rockmusik zu machen ob die begründet
sind oder nicht sehen wir dann
spätestens bei den inszenierungen des
bösen in der rockmusik um uns dann die
frage zu stellen was sie nämlich die
funktionen des bösen in der rockmusik
die rezeption des bösen ist natürlich da
sind auch dann schon bei diesem thema
was beim film auch schon angestellt
machen was sind die gesellschaftlichen
grenzen
wie funktioniert das böse dann in der
gesellschaft wenn es von der rockmusik
kommt und zum schluss ein paar urteile
respektive thesen über das böse was wir
in der rockmusik finden respektive das
scheinbar böse möchte ich eigentlich
vorwegnehmen vorurteile denke ich sind
ihnen bekannt ich habe jetzt mal die
drei rausgesucht die man gängiger weise
hat und die auch am meisten in die
richtung gehen dass wir überhaupt von
dem bösen in der rockmusik reden das
klassische vorteile rockmusik macht
aggressiv sie kennen sicher bilder von
wacken von diversen rock open airs wo
man unten sohn moshpit hat sich leute
scheinbar gegenseitig nur noch irgendwie
zusammentreten und so weiter muss man
sagen stimmt rein körperlich aber es hat
mit böse nichts zu tun sondern es läuft
schon nach bestimmten regeln und
es gibt auch relativ selten verletzt
dazu und wenn sie auch schwanger auf
rock festival fahren es wird ihnen
nichts passieren es ist kein mensch
aggressiv beim festival aber das
vorurteil erstmal diese aggression
dieser aggressivität inszeniert durch
solche bilder wie man sie vom publikum
kennt in kombination mit musik bringt
natürlich sehr schnell dieses vorurteil
erst mal hoch dass das was mit
aggression zu tun hat kommt vielleicht
auch daher dass man rockmusik und
rockmusiker rockmusik fans sehr leicht
auch mit rockern verbinden entspricht
den klassischen harley davidson rockern
die jetzt ja vielleicht auch nicht so
das beste in der gesellschaft haben
obwohl eigentlich bereiche nicht
zwingend etwas miteinander zu tun haben
müssen also nicht jeder rocker oder
rockmusik fan fährt auch hd also ich
habe nicht meinen motorradführerschein
dementsprechend ist die trennung immer
schon auf zu machen aber das bild das
image das wir erst mal vielleicht über
rock musiker haben kommt natürlich auch
daher aber seien sie versichert wenn sie
das als aufklärung style von heute schon
mal mit dem rockers ähnlich aggressiv
punkt zweites vorteil walker sind
natürlich kriminelle rockmusik macht
kriminell
auch das ist ein ganz beliebtes
vorurteil sie kennen das mit sicherheit
auch aus der gesellschaftlichen debatte
über solche filmen wie bowling for
columbine wonach jedem attentat oder
massaker an schulen erstmal der cd
schrank des täters durchwühlt wird und
sich sonst immer herausgestellt hat wo
gott der hat marilyn manson gehört der
up metallica gehört ergo musik macht
kriminell aggressiv böse aber auch das
ist natürlich nur ein vorteil sie werden
später auch noch sehen warum damit
verbunden immer diese dieses thema die
schauen ja alle immer so zuwider
das ist alles so aggressiv dass ist
humorlos das hat immer so was von kampf
von seiner verbissenheit die rockmusiker
oder rockmusikfans ausstrahlen und auch
das ist natürlich nur ein vorurteil das
nicht stimmt aber zu diesem bild des
bösen natürlich dazugehört wenn sie sich
das klassische
auftaktkonzert beim wacken open air
anschauen wo dann 70.000 heavy metal
fans zur blaskapelle der freiwilligen
feuerwehr wacken tanzen dann sieht man
das hat mit aggressivität mit
humorlosigkeit gar nichts mehr zu tun
da wird geschunkelt und es gibt mit
sicherheit kein musik genre das sich
weniger ernst nimmt als die rockmusik
dementsprechend auch diese einstellung
die humorlosigkeit und damit verbunden
dieses jahr verbissen kämpfen der
gehässige ist auch einfach nur ein
vorurteil aber wie gesagt diese bilder
sind natürlich erstmal in der
gesellschaft da damit verbundenen auch
die frage ja die nehmen ja alle drogen
sowie die aussehen auch den spruch kennt
man sehr häufig als rockmusik fan
in der tat wird natürlich sehr stark zum
drogenkonsum aufgerufen in der rockmusik
szene allerdings nur alkohol also andere
drogen wären sie beim festival oder auch
bei konzerten nicht finden
wenn dann bleibt es beim bier aber das
ist alles irgendwie an der nadel hängen
ist natürlich einfach gespannt
dementsprechend auch ein vorurteil dass
ich nicht wirklich aber nicht
ansatzweise bestätigt aber auch
tatsächlich gesellschaftlich verbreitet
ist und die man sich ab und zu aus
herumschlagen muss der klassiker sei
dass rockmusik ab ende der 60er gibt das
sind alles satanisten die schlachten
nachts katzen auf friedhöfen und er ist
ein kleine kinder auf all das kennt man
natürlich provoziert von heavy metal
szene natürlich natürlichem auch durch
quasi den metal gruß in anderen kreisen
dass teufelshörnchen oder der satans
gruß auch dass ein gängiges vorurteil
und satanismus wenn uns vorher noch im
film er schon gehört der teufel ist so
als das sinnbild des bösen natürlich
immer präsent und man spielt natürlich
auch ein bisschen mit diesem image aber
ich bin jetzt glaube ich 20 jahre lang
in der rockmusik szene unterwegs ich
kenne keinen einzigen fatalisten ich
habe noch nie nachts in münchen
geschlachtet oder so was also auch das
ist einfach nur ein vorurteil das aber
einfach in der gesellschaftlichen
wahrnehmung noch sehr präsent ist und
wenn selbst papst franziskus schon so
macht dann gehe ich davon aus dass wir
auch frei von satanismus sind aber diese
vorteile sind nun mal da und unterlegen
oder unterstreichen erstmal da muss
irgend was böse sein in dieser musik und
wären diese vorurteile natürlich nicht
da und dementsprechend gilt es natürlich
soziologisch rauszufinden naja wer
gründen sich eigentlich genau diese
vorurteile warum hat man diese bilder im
kopf wenn man ein heavy metal denkt wenn
man ein rockmusiker denkt warum ist
dieses image der bösen musik einfach in
der gesellschaft präsent und genau dem
wollen wir ein bisserl auf den grund
gehen
ein paar grundannahmen dazu ganz klar
wenn wir von den bösen inszenierungen in
der rockmusik reden dann liegt das daran
dass wir einfach erst mal völlig
verschiedene faktoren haben an was man
das böse überhaupt identifiziert bei den
einen ist es vielleicht das aussehen bei
den anderen die texte bei vielen reicht
allein die die musik dieses geschrei
diese härte diese lautstärke
dementsprechend analytisch müssen wir
uns erstmal völlig verschiedenen feldern
zu wenden an denen sichtbar wird was
vielleicht das böse in der rockmusik
sein kann
damit verbunden wie werden diese
faktoren eigentlich inszeniert das ist
dann ähnlich wie bei der filmanalyse
dinge sind nicht per se böse auch erst
der kontext macht letztendlich das böse
und wir bezeichnen natürlich dinge auch
nur als böse ich denke das ist relativ
klar zu sagen dass rockmusik nicht per
se böse ist sondern dass wir natürlich
hier auch immer von zuschreibungen reden
und böse sind die dinge genannt wenn sie
als solche bezeichnet werden aber es
gilt natürlich sich um das genauer
anzuschauen
die haben warum werden ist eigentlich
das böse bezeichnet was genau
konstituiert dieses bild des bösen und
die freude ist natürlich wir haben
erstmal immer wenn wir von rockmusik
regen
dass das böse in der eine zuschreibung
auch in bestimmten diskurs formationen
dass das heißt wenn die metal-szene
unter sich über die rockmusik oder über
bands redet dann wird da kein mensch
sagen oh gott wir sind so böse und das
haben wir dann wieder böse lieder
produziert es ist dann schon eher eine
zuschreibung von außen sprechen
beobachtender diskurs vielleicht ein
externer diskurs der für touristen
diskurs der vielleicht die böse oder die
bösartigkeit in der rockmusik sehen will
aber es ist natürlich unter den fans
viel weniger das thema dementsprechend
haben wir natürlich erst mal diese art
der zu akt der zuschreibung und folge 2
da wird es dann für mich als soziologe
an spannendsten und das ist auch
perspektive die ich eigentlich einnehme
dass sich das böse immer in der
vernetzung erst mal zeigt die sprache
allein der text allein die musik die
performance der band macht nicht was
böses es muss schon eigentlich ein
fahrrad von kombination sein wie man
dann später auch sehen werden und
dementsprechend ist mein blick immer
wenn man das mal methodologische noch
kurz anreißen will der aktion netzwerk
blick spricht die die frage in welcher
form der akt ahnten generiert sich das
böse
welche dinge emotionen zuschreibungen
sprachlich konstruktionen führen
eigentlich dazu dass wir was als böse in
der rockmusik identifizieren und die
frage eben auch wie kann man die
inszenierung anhand dieses
zusammenspiels von faktoren eigentlich
interpretieren
und das ist durchaus dann wechseln er
sehr differenzierte analyse und ich
werde ein bisschen einen kleinen
überblick geben was man genau an
verschiedenen netzwerken der
inszenierung sich dabei genauer
anschauen kann
um vielleicht dann auf das böse in der
rockmusik zu kommen und ganz klar ist
erst mal der hauptaspekt warum wir von
böser rockmusik reden sind natürlich die
texte sofern man sie natürlich versteht
dass er bei rockmusik auch nicht schon
immer ganz klar dass man die texte hört
man muss sie oft auch erst lesen und
wenn man sie liest wirken sich das noch
viel schlimmer als wenn man sie hört
aber was beinhalten die texte der
rockmusik und ich würde mal sagen das
was ich abbildet betrifft 90 prozent der
texte wir werden erstmal sehr stark und
individueller gewalt kommt
also gewalten sich selbst gewalt in
andere alles was auf einer in die wälder
individuellen ebene der emotionen der
triebhaftigkeit passiert wenn man es mit
nietzsche sagen will dass um das
allzumenschliche wird letztendlich
vielleicht thematisiert oder umgekehrt
das unmenschliche sprich perversion
aggression
all diese themen die wir zum beispiel
als im schlager nicht ansatzweise hören
finden wir natürlich in der rockmusik
sehr stark thematisiert die
auseinandersetzung mit dem triebhaften
und vielleicht sondern da auch schon
noch mal bei einem philosophen von
gestern wenn man immer den tourismus
aufmacht emotion versus ratio das eben
die rockmusik sich sondern er sehr stark
auf die emotionen und weniger vielleicht
auf die reine vernunft und das
vernünftige bezieht sondern ihr genau
diese triebhaftigkeit des menschen
spricht das eigentlich ja philosoph
bestreitet seine schlechte thematisiert
eines der hauptthema tischen fehler dass
wenn er auch musik finden
zweiter punkt ich habe das soziale
gewalt mal genannt und impliziert
letztendlich alles was wir an sozialen
strukturen und so weiter haben
unterdrückung von freiheiten von
minderheiten diskriminierungen macht der
medien umweltzerstörungen all diese
formen die wir natürlich an gesellschaft
kritisieren sind eines der hauptthemen
in der rockmusik also sprich permanent
nur themen wo es um zerstörung geht wo
es um machtmissbrauch geht all das
finden wir in der rockmusik sehr stark
thematisiert meistens als kritik an
solchen struktur natürlich aber es wird
erst mal genauso thematisiert damit
verbundene politische gewalt rassismus
extremismus krieg ein riesen thema
gerade in großen bereichen heavy metal
all das auch jetzt nicht themen wo man
sich haben zum beispiel hinsetzen
entspannen kann sondern die einfach
durchaus einen mit themen konfrontieren
die jetzt nicht die angenehmsten sind
religiöse gewalt insbesondere im linken
bereich der punkmusik riesenthema der
machtmissbrauch durch kirche die dog
matti sierung überhaupt macht von
religion auf den einzelnen menschen
sinne von gehirnwäsche im sinne von
abhängigkeit weil das bereich der
rockmusik sehr stark thematisiert und
zuletzt natürlich drogenmissbrauch und
individuell existenzielle themen sie
werden kaum eine andere musikrichtung
finden die sich so stark mit tod mitleid
mit sterben mit krankheit beschäftigt
und wenn man sich das ganze paket
anschaut dann sind wir bei ungefähr
würde ich jetzt mal sagen 95 prozent
aller texte die wir in rockmusik haben
und dass der sätze nicht unbedingt
textarten oder themen sind bei denen man
fröhlich eine flasche sekt aufmacht ist
klar das ist natürlich das bild
unterstreicht naja die verstehen ja
keinen spaß weil sich sicher natürlich
ständig mit solchen themen beschäftigen
und einfach nur das böse auch in einer
form thematisieren weil natürlich diese
ganzen themen in gewisser weise sehr
stark mit bösen bösartigkeiten verbunden
sind rundet das bild natürlich allein
auf der textuellen ebene schon erstmal
ab die natürlich dieses bild immer noch
weiter verstärkt dass man von böser
rockmusik redet warum weil sie erst mal
böse themen thematisiert macht die ganze
sache nicht leichter dazu kommt
natürlich wenn man von der sexuellen
ebene weg geht auf die performative
ebene von bands gestaltung von cover sie
kennen klassische heavy metal cover rock
musik aber wir haben einerseits diese
struktur dass man immer irgendwelche
monster aliens meistens in form von
skeletten totenköpfen und so weiter hat
immer wüst dargestellt meistens mit
waffen oder auf einer anderen ebene
vielleicht mythische gestalten krieger
soldaten auch meistens mit irgendwelchen
waffen dabei eventuell auch im
schlachtfeld stehen zuges bei dem cover
sehr schön dargestellt das denke ich mal
dass der großteil der heavy metal covers
dass wir finden also auch diese spiel
mit mystischen mit todes gestalten die
das ganze in bissel versinnbildlichen
sollen andere dinge wer hier hatten es
gar mit kindern aufgehängte kinder an
der wäscheleine ist jetzt auch kein bild
was unbedingt
zu freudensprüngen einlädt oder hier bei
rammstein diese szene wie eine nackte
frau geschlachtet wird auch jetzt nicht
unbedingt ein bild das großartige
fröhlichkeit ausdruck sondern eher schon
auf die bösartigen triebe des menschen
verweist aber eben solche szenen
touristische darstellungen von töten von
körper missbrauch sind sehr beliebte
motive bei rockmusik totenköpfe in jeder
form sind natürlich in meiner ganzen
rockmusik szene permanent präsent
funktionalität der totenköpfe werden um
ein thema für sich aber das gibt
natürlich überall oder auch solche
szenen dass sich der meistens der
frontsänger oder der gitarrist und so
einer kampfpause würde man so will auch
inszeniert dass man so diese
aggressivität schon der bühnen
darstellung in gewisser weise auf dem
cover zeigt auch das nicht ein sehr
beliebtes visuelles stilmittel allein um
die cd an den mann zu bringen
aufmerksamkeit damit auch zu generieren
aber eben auch darstellung von themen
die jetzt nicht per se blumenwiese und
ein fröhliches kind oder sowas zeigen
sondern die person die bösen themen
visuell umsetzen damit verbunden
natürlich bühnenshows jeder der mal
einen stein bühnenshow war wird sehen
naja da wäre jetzt auch nicht gerade mit
konfetti geworfen sondern in anderen
dingen
hier hat man ausschnitt von iron maiden
schon relativ beliebtes stilmittel das
man bei bühnenshows finden dass im
hintergrund auch irgendwelche monster
kampfszenen schlachten blut spritzen etc
gezeigt wird sehr oft sind diese
aufbauten gerade bei den großen bühnen
auch im sinne von schlachtfeldern von
kriegsschiffen all das wird da sehr
stark inszeniert wenn man sich zum
beispiel eine metallic aschauer annimmt
kommen von manchem lied erst mal fünf
minuten feuerwerk kanonenschläge und so
weiter und kriegs thema einzuführen bei
rammstein gibt es da mal diese eine
szene wo der keyboarder scheinbar
geschlachtet wird und den kopf auch koch
topf geschmissen wird bei sed sie haben
wir permanent den großen teufel und
kanonenschläge die bei verschiedenen
liedern einsetzen das ganze natürlich
visuell immer untermalt
sehr gern wie mehr menschen hier auch
mit einer richtigen shotgun auf der
bühne war dann auch irgendwie ein oder
irgendwas ziel gerade auch rammstein
diese feuershow das verbrennen von
dingen das zerstören von dingen ein
traditionelles showelement bei
zahlreichen heavy-metal-bands also
dieses image man muss auf der bühne
irgendwas kaputt schlagen denke ich hat
auch jeder schon mal gesehen
gerade beim elementen der hat das in den
90ern schon fast als kunstform gemacht
wie eigentlich bei jedem konzert seine
bühne kaputt geschlagen hat hat sich rhi
dann auch so etabliert wurde auch von
vielen anderen bands unternommen also
gerade auch der bereich feuer wiesen
thema es gibt kaum mehr rock band nicht
irgendwo auch pyrotechnik einsetzt um
irgendwie das verderben das verbrennen
in einer gewissen weise zu illustrieren
also auch das ist natürlich alles
ästhetische mittel wenn man so will die
jetzt nicht auf großartige fröhlichkeit
sondern immer schon auf zerstörung auf
destruktive tät auf kampf auf krieg
ausgelegt sind war es das ganze image
oder die inszenierung des bösen
natürlich noch herrlich untermalt je
nachdem wie gut das auch durchgesetzt
wird dazu kommt natürlich die
namensgebung von vielen bands wenn sie
sich so was wie manowar anschauen men of
war böhse onkelz tragen ist natürlich
schon im namen black sabbath auch jetzt
relativ eindeutig rammstein stehe der
eigentlich als symbol für das schlimme
flugzeugunglück auf der airbase ramstein
daher hat natürlich rammstein den namen
also man bedient sich in der flugzeug
katastrophe mit vielen toten
andere wären so was wie was haben wir
denn beispielsweise schönen of bodom in
flames arch enemy einer maske
theologische nordische
aussage die auch zum krieg geht lamb of
god rise against all diese nicht nur
visuellen darstellung in den namen auch
die namensgebungen selber iron maiden
auch ein klassiker natürlich verweisen
jetzt auch schon in ihrer namensgebung
oft auf ein aggressives thema auf ein
gesellschaftlich böses fehlt wenn man so
will testament sprich todessehnsucht
oder auch der tod die man thematisiert
all diese namen schreien jetzt nicht
unbedingt so im vergleich zum
kastelruther spatzen nach einer romantik
sondern eher schon nach relativ harten
themen nach bösen themen das im
zusammenspiel mit show mit text mit
natürlich der musikalischen darstellung
macht dieses bild des bösen natürlich
immer noch plastischer dazu kommt dass
auftreten auch das kennen sie vielleicht
wie manche band sich inszenieren
slipknot werden momentan oder so ein
paar jahren eine der bands die permanent
mit horrormasken auftritt in völlig
verschiedenen formen meistens aus
irgendwelchen horrorfilmen angehen diese
masken sieht jetzt auch nicht so aus wie
man sich zum kindergeburtstag einladen
will also dieses martialische auftreten
bösartige masken horrormasken auch oft
mythologische masken
sie kennen es bei klassischen heavy
metal bands alle in schwarz alle mit
langen haaren meistens irgendwie grimmig
dreinschauen
viele sind jetzt ja auch einen von der
statur nicht unbedingt der magersucht
entsprungen sondern eher schon solche
mannsbilder das proforma natürlich auch
gern tattoos gehören mittlerweile in
natürlichen bereit dazu allerdings nicht
immer nur frag' musik beschränkt sondern
überall oder hier auch bei dem bild von
frei.wild man hat immer fotos von bands
und auf darstellungen immer diesen
unglaublich aggressiven blick diese
härte diese unnahbarkeit eine gewisse
distanz und kälte auch so eine art
verachtung des anderen gegenüber
die jetzt natürlich auch durchaus auch
seinen bösen charakter hinweisen können
wir haben es vorhin bei den film
bösewichten gehabt
wenn einer schon mit namen im gesicht
und so daherkommt dann schau ist er
vermutlich auch irgendwie der bösewicht
und bands machen das natürlich sehr
gerne in ihrem auftreten dass sie mit
diesem image letztendlich natürlich auch
spielen und diese bösartigkeit oder
scheinbare bissigkeit bösartigkeit
natürlich immer rein durch ihr auftreten
auch inszenieren fan kultur ist
natürlich dasselbe fans adaptieren das
ganze eher sehr stark diese aufkleber
sehen sie sehr häufigen den autos hinten
drauf wenn man diese identifikation mit
dem wacken festival die identifikation
mit der marke kommt natürlich hinzu und
was sie natürlich bei ganz vielen fans
von bands immer haben ist natürlich der
ganz klassische t shirt kult ich habe
natürlich vorher nicht gezeigt aber
sämtliche metal klamotten sind natürlich
immer schwarz es gibt kaum bund im metal
shirts wir haben immer irgendwie monster
tot irgendwelche dinge drauf damit
verbundenen nieten armbänder totenköpfe
leder in dem fall auch patronen mit
drauf irgendwelche schwarzen
schmuckgegenstände ketten kreuze mit
totenköpfen all dessen natürlich im
bereich der fan-kultur die medien oder
die stilmittel mit denen man natürlich
auch diese diese ja dieses image des
bösen des unnahbaren viel stärker noch
inszenieren kann also mit sicherheit
haben sie schon ab und zu gedacht wenn
in ihnen irgendwie 34 so mettler
entgegen kommen die dann vielleicht alle
so angezogen waren lange haare gehören
natürlich bei vielen immer noch dazu bei
neueren mettler nicht mehr die haben uns
kurze haare
aber dann wären sie auch gedacht haben
wenn die da alle herkommen auf noch mit
lederjacke und so weiter und so fort
das sind sicher nicht die friedlichsten
zeitgenossen sicherheit hat noch der ein
oder anderen bier dabei gehabt
dementsprechend impfen im bereich der
fan-kultur im ausleben der fan liebe
finden wir natürlich dieses spiel mit
diesen arten oder der der inszenierung
sehr stark damit verbunden natürlich und
bands wissen dass wir sie dieses image
vermarkten müssen dass man damit
natürlich richtig kasse machen kann
das wäre ein eigener vortrag wenn wir
die vermarktungsstrategien von heavy
metal reden wo natürlich das böse image
permanent dargestellt wird das fängt bei
den kleinsten an also er ist ein kind
schon quasi in der wiege und im
kindergarten als das bett teilt
inszenieren will der nimmt sich
irgendwie den motor herz strampelanzug
oder einen ganzen los strampelanzug und
dann ist das kleine quasi schon in der
wiege der bad boy wenn man so will
für ältere generationen die schon eher
an das jenseits lenken gibt es die
eigene sache edition von der band kiss
zum beispiel auch so ein artikel der
jetzt nicht umhin darauf verweist dass
seine band etwas fröhliches haben kann
sondern wo man auch allein durch solche
darstellungen doch solche marketing
artikel natürlich zeigt naja wir wollen
uns schon irgendwie von helene fischer
abgrenzen also auch das spiel hier
tatsächlich mit tod und dieser brutale
fan kult der das eigentlich inszeniert
wird dieser sack kostet 300.000 dollar
also muss und wir leisten können weil
man mit kers ins jenseits will aber das
gehört dann zu denen ich den ganzen
spiel mit diesen bösen image dazu und
lässt natürlich gerade im bereich des
marketing extrem viel zu wenn man sich
diverse kataloge anschaut was folgt
daraus
wir haben uns erst mal so ein berg an
arten von inszenierung was natürlich gar
nicht mit drin ist das ist die musik
selbst wenn wir auf rockmusik klänge
gehen wenn wir auf heavy metal gehen
wenn wir auf die art der musik
inszenierung gehen da ich kein
musikwissenschaftler blende ich das
jetzt mal aus sie kennen heavy metal in
gewisser weise wie mutig mal
und natürlich wird der bereich der klang
funk oder der klang inszenierungen der
schnellen riffs dass wir es auch im
gesang wo man ja sehr oft eigentlich
nicht die texte versteht spielt
natürlich noch hinzu dass 100
letztendlich die ganze inszenierung ab
aber das was wir einfach so an anderen
faktoren beobachten können außerhalb der
musik rundet natürlich dieses bild von
diesen bösen image letztendlich erst ab
wenn die musik selber ist es nicht
so wird man ins herz treffen aber sehr
oft so was wie rammstein rein
musikalisch auch mit wagner verglichen
wenn sie sehen dass die metal und black
metal mittlerweile im oberen
kulturbereich angekommen sind alles
gerühmt sich damit dass sie heavy metal
konzerte live übertragen ja weil es
quasi eine neue kultur ist dann geht
natürlich ein bisschen der verdacht das
ist jetzt an der musik auch selber
league des bösen weg und die musik
selber ist es auch nicht so wenn ich da
sagen mal auch als kronzeugen meine
mutter nehmen die hört unglaublich gern
metallica wenn es geschrei nicht wer
also die melodien selber die gitarren
das schlagzeug
das ist oft quasi erträglich geht
tatsächlich oft schon eine klassische
richtung aber hat natürlich ohne das
geschreie den gesang bei weiten nicht
diese härte oder auch vielleicht dieses
eben böse image als ohne hat deswegen
ist auch dieser diese kombination
classic hätten oft gar nicht weit weg
und sehr viele heavy metal musiker hören
permanent klassik um sich davon
inspirieren zu lassen
dementsprechend habe ich den bereich
weggelassen das wäre wahrscheinlich dem
bereich gewesen den die frau fricke
gemacht hat kann man auch darüber reden
ob das per se böse musikklänge gibt wie
es vielleicht dasselbe auch im film mit
gibt es positive elemente
ich würde sagen nein aber das wäre so
eine frage zur diskussion ob musik
allein qual des klangs etwas böses an
sich haben kann kann man gerne nachher
diskutieren die frage ist natürlich
jetzt aber für soziologen naja was
bringt das eigentlich wenn man dieses
ganze bösartig ist inszeniert welche
wirkweisen hat das ganze für wen und
warum
und das hat natürlich ganz klar erstmal
im bereich identifikation und
selbstdarstellung also wenn man sich
auch überlegt woher rockmusik kommt
gegen was man sich vielleicht für andere
schauen was auch abgrenzen musste dann
zeigt man natürlich quasi eines rockers
1 durchaus ein gewisses statement was
man sein will
jeder der sich natürlich auch sei ihr
als band oder als fan
dementsprechend kleidet weiß worauf er
sich einlässt
gibt sicher gerne auch in diese schiene
der vorurteile
dementsprechend ist dieses image das
irgendwie bösen des outlaw das gegen die
gesellschaft stehenden natürlich erst
mal ein ganz großes element auf der
personalen ebene
diese identifikation und
selbstdarstellung weil man muss auch
ganz klar sagen oft ist dieses bild von
musikern dass die produzieren
selbstdarstellung ist wenn man sich so
eine band rammstein nimmt die sagen ganz
klar naja wenn mir auf der bühne sind
wenn wir interviews geben da spielen wir
da theater das sind nicht wir sondern
das ist halt unser shop rammstein zu
sein und das ist natürlich durchaus dann
im bereich der selbstdarstellung
irgendwie anzusehen bei anderen bands
ist natürlich durch ihren so eine
herzenssache und eine starke
identifikation aber klar erstmal man
gibt sich aktiv in diese rolle um etwas
darzustellen was auch immer das dann
sein mag wächst letztendlich auch aus
dem grund heraus man will sich von
anderen musikgenres abgrenzen
wenn man sich kurz überlegt woher kommt
rockmusik rockmusik entstand so wenn man
so will mit der der sechziger als
gegenbewegung zu klassischem rock n'
roll zu blues und vor allem zu den
hippies niemand mag hippies in der
rockmusik szene
warum und fröhlich freiheit frieden all
das waren themen dagegen wollten sich
die rocker abgrenzen weil die gesagt
haben so ende 60er hey es ist doch alles
mist hier wir haben arbeitslosigkeit wir
haben den vietnamkrieg usw
wir wollen jetzt hier nicht irgendwie
gesellschaftskritik mit freier liebe
üben sondern wir müssen quasi darstellen
wie brutal eigentlich die welt ist daher
das image mit dem schwarzen mit dem
leder mit den mieten mit dieser ganzen
aggressiven grundhaltung gegen die
gesellschaft und das wird natürlich bis
heute irgendwo gepflegt also man will
sich natürlich auch bewusst vielleicht
von anderen musikgenres abgrenzen
wenngleich das natürlich heutzutage da
teilweise sehr fließend ist wenn sie
sehen dass beispiel so ein mensch wie
florian silbereisen auf einmal mit
schwarzen lederjacke sein volk music
stage moderiert dann wird es natürlich
schwierig sich abzugrenzen aber
zumindest war dass man auch im
grundanliegen
der abgrenzung rein optisch rein visuell
rein textlich das obere motiv auf der
textuellen ebene ist natürlich immer
gesellschaftskritik also auch musik will
gesellschaft kritisieren sie will auf
missstände aufmerksam machen aufmerksam
machen und das funktioniert natürlich
nur wenn ich gesellschaft mit dem
konfrontiert was sie verdrängt sprich
das böse das unmenschliche missstände
missbrauch all das ist natürlich das
höhere ziel um gesellschaftskritik zu
üben und damit eben insbesondere dieses
böse genau da zu thematisieren um diese
bösartigkeiten die in der welt
stattfinden sichtbar zu machen also
letztendlich spiegelt rockmusik
eigentlich nur das wieder was in der
gesellschaft eigentlich passiert und was
wir aber so vielleicht normalen
entertainment alt alltag auch gar nicht
hören oder sehen wollen weil man
natürlich nicht permanent mit dem leiden
der welt konfrontiert sein will
rockmusik tut das aber damit einher
gehen eben diese klimatisierung des
bösen
diese flucht in die heile welt wie es
andere musikbranche machen das will
rockmusik natürlich nicht als rockmusik
geht genau den anderen weg und sagt nee
wir dürfen nicht quasi in die heile welt
flüchten sondern wir müssen uns der
bösartigkeit stellen die uns im leben
begegnet und genau das wird natürlich
thematisiert und eben das was wir
gemeinhin als das böse auch in der welt
sehen sei das rot sei dass krankheit sei
dass krieg das wird eben durch rockmusik
wenn man so will immanent gemacht
kritisiert inszeniert und der punkt der
sinn stiftung und des nhs ist natürlich
auf der ebene des persönlichen der
entscheidende
wir haben vorhin im film vertrag diese
these dass gewalt bösartigkeit empfehlen
button katharsis element der katharsis
ist genau das ist es natürlich in der
rockmusik auch wenn sie auch zum
rockkonzert sind und sich zwei stunden
vor ausgaben und gegen und vielleicht
sogar zwei stunden so moshpit verbringen
danach sind sie fällig also dass jede
form von aggressivität aus ihnen raus da
ist genau dieses hören und erleben von
rockmusik das katarische element
man glaubt ja immer wenn man diese musik
gehört wird man aggressiv genau das
gegenteil ist der fall also genau
deswegen hört man eigentlich die musik
um irgendwo in gewisser weise dieses ja
man kann durchaus sagen sie ihren heil
für sich zu gewinnen oder zu finden wenn
sie sich fan briefe von fans an die
bands anschauen dann finden sie genau
diesen bereich wo immer beschrieben wird
eure musik hilft mir über meine sorgen
wegzukommen erst eure musik werde ich
irgendwie in meiner seele fündig wer ich
bin
eure musik hilft mir irgendwie dahin zu
kommen wo ich immer hinwollte hilft mir
irgendwie leiden zu überwinden
all das finden wir in diesem bereich und
das ist letztendlich der bereich wo es
auch drauf ankommt sprich was hilft
diese musik oder diese thematisierung
des bösen im speziellen dem einzelnen
der ganze teil ist schön und gut das
passiert halt so außen rum aber das
warum die fans letztendlich diese musik
kaufen das liegt natürlich genau in
diesem bereich weil genau diese
thematisierung des bösen im text in der
darstellung ein bedürfnis der menschen
erfüllt dass das ein mangel letztendlich
belebt und einfach dementsprechend
sinnstiftend oder seelenheil bringen
sein kann ist für außenstehende oft
schwierig zu verstehen aber das ist
letztendlich das was sie von jedem fan
hören warum er genau solche musik hört
und natürlich das bleibt nicht außen vor
das ganze ist natürlich ein
vermarktungsinstrument ich kann
natürlich mit diesem böse image mit
diesen wert band thema durchaus kasse
machen also dran standen müssen jetzt
nicht so auftreten wie sie auftreten um
geld zu verdienen aber in dem moment wo
sie natürlich sich in der toten kutsche
über das brandenburger tor ziehen lassen
wird das natürlich schon noch mal ein
bisschen anders und dementsprechend
nutzen wenn es natürlich genau dieses
image des bösen als vermarktung ich habe
es gerade schon gesagt und diese
funktion liegt natürlich auch daran dass
das böse wir haben also auf und schon
gehabt in der gewissen weise sexy ist
natürlich zieht das an
warum auch immer das sein mag welche uhr
bedürfnisse das vielleicht leidet
ein oder anderen stellt das überlasse
man im psychologen aber natürlich zieht
dieses image des bösen das ist ganz klar
und diese art auch der coolness warum
vielleicht jugendliche irgendwann
anfangen heavy metal zu hören hat
natürlich da auch seinen reiz und das
wird dann nicht auf der vermarktungs
ebene erst mal völlig ausgekühlt da
braucht man nicht zu diskutieren
die rezeption des bösen im heavy metal
in der rockmusik hängt natürlich sehr
stark damit zusammen auf welche
funktionsweise ich mich beziehen oder
genau diese funktionsweise auf der
individuellen ebene kommt relativ
schnell selten vor vielmehr finden wir
erstmal natürlich die mediale rezeption
in dem moment wo bands wie böhse onkelz
wie rammstein wie metallica neues album
rausbringen den euro ankündigen geht der
mediale ausschreibungs warum es geht
immer darum tabubrüche zu thematisieren
und die gefahren dieser musik zu
definieren zu können die uhr danach
stellen wenn beispielsweise freiwild im
frühjahr nach münchen kommen
das feuilleton der süddeutschen mit voll
sein und warnen wo gott geht nicht zu
dieser bösen band weil die verdirbt eure
kinder zu nazis all das wird medial
erstmal aufbereitet und dementsprechend
geht es in der medialen rezeption des
bösen in der rockmusik immer um die
tabus wenn rammstein neues album
rausbringt dann ist die hauptfrage
welche tabus brechen sie jetzt wieder
und man versucht weil sie genau diese
bösen themen und die inszenierung des
bösen dann medial auszuarbeiten
für die touristen für musikredakteure
ist sowas natürlich ein gefundenes
fressen über ein helene fischer konzert
ja kann man jetzt nicht so viel sagen da
kann man sich nicht so erregen aber
diese öffentliche erregung die in den
medien natürlich ab gespiegelt wird ist
natürlich auch wiederum ein gewisses
stilmittel wie sich die bands
inszenieren aber genau tabus sind das
thema worum sich der medialen diskurs
dreht geht dann immer sehr schnell über
einen politischen diskurs also heavy
metal und rock musik alben gehen immer
auch in die richtung naja müssen wir
unseren jugendschutz verändern also
diese fsk18 kennzeichnungen
sind immer ein thema wie viel welche
gewalt oder brutalität der von einem
jugendlichen zumuten in der musik geht
in die richtung film
sprich auch die gefahr der nachahmung
ich habe es vorher schon gesagt spielt
da immerhin her also welche obszönität
der sich eigentlich den jugendlichen
auch bei seiner musik irgendwie sehr
viele aussetzen
gerade am stein ist ja immer auch wieder
vorne dabei wenn es um indizierung geht
dass sie diverse textzeilen nicht singen
dürfen weil böse gesellschaftlich führt
das ganze natürlich immer ins tun das
ist durchaus positiv zu sehen dass wir
moralische und ethische debatten führen
also die frage die rockmusik oft
aufwirft ist durchaus dann die frage
wieviel bösartigkeit dürfen wir
eigentlich der menschheit zumuten genau
das ist dann das thema wie viel
vertragen unsere jugendlichen ist so
eine textzeile wie stacheldraht im harn
kanal irgendwas bösartiges kann man das
jugendlichen unter 18 zumuten können
dieses reflektieren bis wohin dürfen wir
themen eigentlich setzen die in dem
bereich der unmenschlichkeit gehen wenn
sie sich zum beispiel den fall des
kannibalen von rotenburg nehmen den hat
rammstein ja durchaus auch vertont in
dem lied mein teil
und da gab es dann eine debatte darüber
hat erfahren darüber singen
und lustigerweise hat der kannibale von
rotenburg am stand sogar verklagt wegen
persönlichkeitsrechten dass er quasi das
allen gerecht zu erzählung seiner
kannibalen geschichte hat und dann stand
das nicht machen da aber da ging die
diskussion los wie für kannibalismus
haben wir eigentlich in unserer
gesellschaft wenn sie beispielsweise den
fritzl in österreich nehmen der die
kinder da eingesperrt hat auch das wurde
natürlich von benz vorstellt wo es auch
darum geht na ja davon eigentlich dieses
leid der kinder so thematisieren und wie
viel solche fritzls wohnen eigentlich
noch in deutschland oder in österreich
die irgendwie im keller verstecken also
sehr viele themen werden durch wird
musik oder durch solche bands erstmal
wieder dann auch gesellschaftlich
gespiegelt sie verschwinden dann eben
nicht in der tagesschau sondern werden
auf einmal umgesetzt und führen dann
genau zu diesen debatten
na ja wie viele bösartigkeit ist
eigentlich in unserer welt
wie stark können wir auf der
künstlerischen seite diese bösartigkeit
ausreizen und dementsprechend diese
rezeption auf gesellschaftsebene
unglaublich wichtig wenn wir uns über
grenzen des moralischen und bösen
eigentlich unterhalten wollen
kommerziell ich habe es gesagt wird auch
das natürlich genau so rezitiert und
diese böse ästhetik die permanent
dargestellt wird wird man sich als marke
inszeniert und dementsprechend auch
durchaus von sagen wir mal
wirtschaftlicher seite gewürdigt also
man kann sich durchaus viel in der
rockmusik abschauen wie man so eine
marke macht auf der künstlerischen
rezeptions ebene ist es natürlich so und
das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt rockmusik
genuin sondern betrifft glaube die ganze
kunst immer die frage wo sind die
grenzen also wie weit darf ich mit
meiner kunst gehen
der häufig eine lebendige zu einem haken
in dem museum aufhängen ist das kunst
oder nicht ähnliches findet mir
letztendlich in rockmusik also wie
brutal der offenen bühnen shows seien
auch bühnenshows werden immer wieder
injiziert man sagt okay das ist jetzt an
der grenze des guten geschmacks auch
wieder natürlich stichwort rammstein die
schon diverse male den usa
beispielsweise für eine nacht in den
knast mussten weil sie so was wie
masturbation auf der bühne gezeigt haben
also auch das war dann denen zu viel das
war nicht mehr tragbar wäre es bei uns
in deutschland nicht der fall aber eben
genau die grenze wie weit kann ich die
bösartigkeiten auf einer bühne
inszenieren oder auch in dem museum im
film in der musik spielt letztlich keine
rolle
aber genau dieses ausloten der grenzen
ist ein riesenthema sie kennen das
vielleicht auch aus dem theater wo man
sich immer wieder die frage gestellt wie
pervers muss eine darstellung eigentlich
sein wie viel nacktheit verträgt theater
all das wird natürlich auch auf das böse
zu treffen und auf den sie ihren des
bösen und natürlich auf die rockmusik
und zuletzt natürlich viele rum die
rezeption auf der individuellen ebene
warum hören einzelne menschen das und
das nochmal genau bei der funktion
dass das individuum eben diese rezeption
von rockmusik prima aus dem grund hat
dass es eine alltags flucht war sie
nicht zwingend abnehmen sondern eben
dieses siegel sorge rischen aspekte in
sich trägt und dass man eben genau das
glück im bösen sucht spricht das gute im
bösen
um eben vielleicht eigene probleme zu
verarbeiten und sich dann vielleicht
auch mit dem sänger und so weiter
identifiziert der vielleicht dieselben
probleme gehabt hat wenn man die böhsen
onkelz denkt der sänger war jahrelang
heroinabhängig und für ganz viele fans
war das ein vorbild von diesem ganzen
weg zu kommen
all das sind mir letztendlich auf der
individuellen ebene wo das ganze durch
rost an den positiven effekt haben kann
weil das negative negative thematisiert
wird abschließend drei tieren die ich zu
diesen bösen aus einer anderen
soziologischen sicht darstellen will die
durchaus glaublich diskussionswürdig
sind aber die man mit sicherheit mal an
diskutieren kann erstens die art wie das
in das böse inszeniert wird oder die
formen der inszenierungen im in der
rockmusik sind unglaublich konservativ
sprich wir benutzen traditionelle
methoden in der performance und in den
texten warum was als böses quasi
inszeniert wird in der rockmusik ist
letztendlich immer mit derselben methode
oder funktioniert mit derselben methode
wir sind irgendwie seit 40 jahren
schwarz gekleidet der totenkopf hat sich
nicht wirklich verändert
die möglichst plakative darstellung des
bösen ist eigentlich immer dieselbe
vielleicht wird es mal ein bisschen
lyrischer oder poetische wenn man sich
solche bands aus dem bereich das dark
wave zum beispiel nimmt oder auch
rammstein im dienst versuchen nicht mehr
zu schreien alles ist scheiße sondern
das kann man auch anders vielleicht
thematisieren aber letztendlich geht es
immer darum wie inszenieren eigentlich
seit 40 50 jahren dasselbe image mit
denselben methoden feuer schwarz
aggressivität böses auftreten all das
ist durchaus was wenn man so will sehr
konservatives man geht jetzt keine neuen
wege sie werden uns also keine heavy
metal band finden die auf einmal in neon
partie posen auf die bühne kommt und dem
und dadurch vielleicht irgendwie
versucht was du isst es zu inszenieren
das funktioniert nicht sprich die art
und weise wie das böse inszeniert wird
sind im gegensatz zum film hier schon
durchaus beschränkt das mag doch die
sprache sowieso per se eingeschränkt
sein aber eben auch diese art der
darstellung ist eigentlich ziemlich
konservativ sprich nicht extrem proxy
strich sehr traditionell mit denselben
methoden weiter arbeiten und das ganze
wird sich vermutlich auch nicht so
schnell ändern
umgekehrt finden wir aber eine ganz
andere struktur was quasi aus der
innenperspektive der rockmusik böse ist
nämlich das natürlich alles was
traditionell und konservativ ist aus
sicht der rockmusik natürlich böse ist
und das ist genau dieses ist sagen wir
mal durch das paradox ist wenn rockmusik
finden dass sie unglaublich viel
konservative strukturen in sich trägt
dass sie unglaublich konservativ
arbeitet ich unterstelle eigentlich
jedem rocker dass er zu 70% csu cdu
wähler ist wenn ich noch mehr
konservativ aber dass genau dieses
eigene konservativ tische dass man in
sich trägt sei dass in der fan kultur
sei da sind der musik sei das in
teamsitzungen das wird nicht als solches
gesehen im gegenteil man versucht sich
genau dagegen eigentlich abzugrenzen das
als das böse zu stilisieren gegnern dass
man eigentlich ist dementsprechend diese
ja wirklich paradox struktur dass man
extrem stark konservativ handelt selber
ist seine eigene rockmusik kultur als
solche lebt die man aber eigentlich
ablehnt warum man es auch nicht als
solches reflektiert wenn ich den vortrag
rein über diese konservativen strukturen
halte und man hat dann so 30-40
metal-fans vorsicht dann sagt man dann
hey ihr seid eigentlich uhr konservativ
das rennen jetzt nicht so gern
also im gegenteil weil das wird
eigentlich genau strikt abgelehnt und
tatsächlich als der feind oder das böse
für die rockmusik bezeichnet obwohl man
es eigentlich selbst inszeniert und
zuletzt ist natürlich auch die die
inszenierung als art von dem bösen
relativ konservativ also es gibt
eigentlich nichts darüber hinaus wie
sich rockmusik selber inszeniert also
das böse was wären wir dann spricht
tatsächlich diese frage ist rockmusik
ohne das böse überhaupt noch rockmusik
oder sind wir dann eigentlich schlager
also gibt es eine rockmusik außerhalb
des bösen und da bin ich mir nicht so
sicher ob da noch was übrig bliebe oder
ob wir dann vielleicht klassik werden
weil wir nur noch melodien haben oder
sind wir dann schlager oder pop man weiß
es nicht genau aber es gibt nur das böse
als unsere formel mit denen wir
eigentlich rockmusik überhaupt am leben
erhalten können und das ist vielleicht
auch kein positiver befund aber ich
glaube das ist ein befunden die man
treffen kann um rockmusik oder den kern
der rockmusik herauszufiltern das eben
genau das böse wiederum in allen formen
wir jetzt gesehen haben eigentlich
antriebsfeder es warum es rockmusik gibt
und ohne böse wer es keine rockmusik
abschließend ein paar zitate natürlich
nicht wissenschaftliche art sondern von
menschen außer viktor eu vielleicht die
was zu sagen haben die musik drückt das
aus was nicht gesagt werden kann und
worüber es unmöglich zu sparen
darüber ist unmöglich ist zu schweigen
genau das ist vielleicht das thema der
rockmusik dass man das was man
eigentlich nicht sagen kann versucht in
einer gewissen weise auszudrücken leiden
schmerz trauer kummer und so weiter und
so fort trifft vielleicht auch rockmusik
sogar ziemlich gut zu noch viel besser
trifft zu ich kann nicht so viel musik
von wagner anhören ich hätte sonst den
drang polen zu erobern
von woody allen sehr spannendes zitat
war es jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt
auf die rockmusik zu trifft aber was
vielleicht beschreibt das auch
vielleicht andere musikarten durchaus zu
bösen handlungen motivieren können was
rockmusik eben gar nicht tut zitat heavy
metal bands the world a better off
sprich mehr heavy metal wird der welt in
ihrer friedlichkeit sehr gut tun von dem
größten metal philosophen die wir haben
bewusst decken sie noch ganz enger von
einem mann eine der erfolgreichsten
heavy metal bands und natürlich das
zitat was vielleicht das konfrontative
es aber genau auch diese böse haltung
von heavy metal ausdrückt
im pop ging es darum zu sagen [ __ ] me im
rock geht es darum [ __ ] you zu sagen
griesheim die sängerin der pretenders
aus den 70ern schon und mein
lieblingszitat das niemandem
zuzuschreiben ist aber dass letztendlich
auch dieses image dass rockmusik so böse
eigentlich ist um zu aggressivität
verleite völlig ad absurdum führt wer
luftgitarre spielt kann keine waffe
erhalten
dementsprechend rockmusik als ein
frieden stiftendes element das aber ohne
tatsächlich das böse zu nicht
thematisieren nicht funktionieren würde
vielen dank
[Applaus]